the relationship between china and the
united states
sure and you know you have sequoias in
china
they're investing then you had trump for
four years
seeming to be at odds with china and
constantly deriding them and the wuhan
virus and things got really weird
and we've spent all this time kind of
integrating
our two economies and obviously you're
kind of like the perfect example of this
you have sequoia
china investing in a company based in
california the product is made in china
it's sold in america you are uh somebody
who grew up in china who now lives in
america
tell me what's your take on the
relationship between these two great
nations
yeah it's actually a passionate subject
of mine um
and it could be touchy you know because
of
politics and the environment that we
lived in today unfortunately but
one of the things i don't know if you've
heard about it jason is uh
this theory called the golden arches uh
theory
have you heard of okay i mean they don't
make mcdonald's golden arches
uh but that's right give me the golden
arches in this regard yeah
so it's basically the concept uh
the law that no two countries that have
mcdonald's have ever gone to war with
each other
so another word to say is a capitalistic
truce right
so it's like two capitalist nations are
less likely to go into war with each
other
and this is a concept that i think was
inspired by the book uh
homo uh homosexuals friedman came up
with it i think i remember this yeah the
golden arches area conflict prevention
once the economies become sufficiently
integrated both costs of going to war
and the amount of contact between the
two countries will increase yeah
that makes that's complete sense yeah
yeah so
in in you know in short uh war used to
be the number one
way of getting resources and that's why
companies that's why countries go to war
uh but if there's really healthy
commerce relationship then there's
no reason to have bloodshed because you
can get what you what you want by just
trading right and so i am a firm
believer in globalization
um i do think that's the story of
human civilization it's just the story
of globalization as we
go from our tribes to villages to cities
to countries to then
earth right um and so yeah having been
someone who
grew up born in china and deeply
ingrained in that in that society
my wife is from china as well and
really receive education and uh
you know have my career here in the in
the u.s i
feel like i owe both countries and both
societies a lot
and i feel but if you ask me are you a
chinese
person or american citizen first of all
i'm american citizen by the passport but
i think of myself more of like a global
citizen
as in you know i i travel between two
countries a lot
i feel like two countries have things
right and wrong they have strong
strength and weaknesses and so i do
think it's all about how do you have the
two of the most powerful nation the
biggest economies
kind of exist in harmony because there's
no other way
right because you whether you like it or
not it's the two most impactful
economies in the world and so all of
that is to say you know i i really
want to one of the things that drive me
at outer is
um how do you bridge the gap of
understanding you know between
the two peoples uh about each other you
know the concept of mating china
used to be derogative because it it
implies yeah
yeah you speak japan was like high
quality china was bad quality
now china is yeah transcendent quality
right like
unbelievable right i mean our iphones
are made there yeah and i think
they built a tesla gigafactory in like
six months
it's incredible the speed at which they
can go
why is sock 2 compliance critically
important you hear it all the time
sock 2 sock 2 well if you don't have
your sock 2 buttoned up
you can't close major companies as
partners and as customers it's that
simple
and guess what vanta is gonna give you a
thousand dollars off
your vanta compliance uh process and
this is something that's very important
what they're gonna do
when you get your sock 2 with vanta is
they're going to continually test
against technical and non-technical sock
to requirements and they also have
partnered with over two dozen auto firms
who have been trained
to file sac2 reports directly in vanta
on average the vanta customers get their
sock 2 compliance in
just 2 3 4 weeks compare that with three
four or five months without vanta
and you understand why everybody's going
crazy about it i just had a twisted
listener uh
john email me he's got the drone stored
up kitty hawk you may have heard of them
they're very famous
and he says vanta was essential in
helping them get sock to compliance up
and running
and he loves their tie-ins to google
slack github and aws
which are all essential apps that run
kitty hawks
awesome business vanta again is giving
twist listeners a thousand dollar
discount on their subscription right now
and i know many of you taking advantage
of it v-a-n-t-a.com
twist vanta.com twist for a thousand
dollars off
okay let's get back to this amazing
episode